all right I feel like the finish line is
in sight we've got our render tree
can we put pixels on the screen now
we're definitely very close but there's
one more set we still need to figure out
where and how all the elements are
positioned on the page that's the layout
step let's take a look the show layout
in action I've come up with a simple
render tree here's what the final result
will look like note that if we rotate
the phone the dimensions of the box is
change but their proportions stayed the
same let's see if we can figure out what
the browser is doing here let's start at
the top we set the background on the
body element to gray that makes sense
that's exactly what we saw and we set
its width to hundred-percent
wait that's a hundred percent of what
exactly it's a hundred percent of the
layout viewport size if you paid
attention our hello world examples
contained an extra meta tag oh yeah I
was reading the web fundamentals guide
on responsive design and it said that I
should always have this tag but I never
really understood what it was for it is
a bit cryptic but let's try to make
sense of it what it's doing is telling
the browser that the width of the layout
viewport should be equal to the device
width so let's say the device width is
320 pixels then if this meta viewport
tag is present the browser will set the
layout viewport to 320 pixels and that
will be our 100% I see but what happens
if I don't provide this tag then the
browser will use the default viewport
width which is typically 980 pixels and
it's optimized for large screens you
know how sometimes sites render zoomed
out and you have to zoom to navigate and
read the text that's because they're not
setting the layout viewport well that
makes sense I am definitely not a big
fan of those sites neither am i to build
great mobile experience you should
always set the matter viewport but
getting back to our example if the
device width is 320 pixels then the body
will be 320 pixels wide next we have the
div node at 50% of the width and it is a
child of body so its width is relative
to its parent and 50% of 320 pixels is
160 pixels and for paragraph the width
is
the percent of its parent giving us the
width of 80 pixels and with that we're
done
that's layout now how about you give it
a try